on vous propose pour les prochaines
minutes retour en arrière si vous le
voulez bien comprendre un peu l'âme de
certains quartiers de montréal vous
voyez des images actuelles du ce qu'il
reste du cinéma empress sur la rue
sherbrooke dans notre dame de grâce il
ya un projet pour revitaliser ce cinéma
et on va parler ensuite avec un invité
de ses efforts qu'on fait dans plusieurs
quartiers pour donner une nouvelle vie à
ces bâtiments historiques mais d'abord
le reportage d'emilie du braille
les années 20 les années folles un peu
partout en amérique du nord ont
construit des cinémas d'atmosphère dans
lesquels le public va voir des bulletins
nouvelles des vaudevilles du cinéma muet
c'est ça la atmosphérique ce qu'on
voulait faire avec le public
ils se retrouvaient vraiment comme dans
un lieu exotique ça faisait voyager ça
faisait ça faisait partie de
l'expérience jeu des fois je me demande
si la salle était le décor était plus
important que le fut construit en 1927
le cinéma l'empress de la rue sherbrooke
ouest est le plus bel exemple de cinéma
d'atmosphère en amérique du nord encore
debout sont m l'egypte ancienne
on venait découvrir la tombe de
toutankhamon
alors c'était toute l'excitation autour
de cette découverte là
ça fait des mois que les nantis et
travaille d'arrache-pied pour que ces
clôtures disparaissent et qu'on puisse
revoir des films à l'inpres si tout va
bien il y aura ici quatre nouvelles
salles de cinéma d'ici quelques mois
alors allons-y
on se trouve dans le ski était lobé
l'entrée sa sono les portes d'entrée qui
sont ici et ce qui sera l'entrée du
futur cinéma dj telle une archéologue
amoureuse de ces découvertes hélène et
il a hâte de faire partager ses trésors
oubliés avec le public et de restaurer
les presses des statuts des des jeunes
filles en jupe sienne j'ai versé
de l'onu
moi je le considère comme un trésor
parce que c'est c'est eh
une pièce super importante dans la
décoration originale du théâtre c'était
le fameux rideau
ça faisait partie du décor de la cour
égyptienne
ici et là des morceaux de costumes en
lambeaux et des pièces d'un décor d'une
comédie musicale d'un autre âge plein
mais tu es une fille
oui le projet de cinéma une dj est
ambitieux 12 millions de dollars si
québec y participent
la majorité du financement viendra
d'investisseurs privés si tout
fonctionne comme prévu
on pourra de nouveau projeté le rêve
dans cette salle au riche passé ici mini
dubreuil radio canada montréal avec moi
jean françois leclercq directeur du
centre d'histoire de montréal monsieur
leclerc bonsoir ça c'est l'exemple de
l'empress sur la rue sherbrooke ouest
donc à notre dame de grâce
on verra ça va fonctionner ce projet-là
d'abord revenons un peu en arrière on
aime et construire si grande et belle
salle à montréal pourquoi ben écoutez on
est dans a comme on dit dans le
reportage dans les années 10 20 on est
vraiment dans le début du cinéma comme
un art populaire extrêmement populaire
et il faut savoir que le cinéma l'époque
c'est une sorte des maisons de la
culture populaire il y avait à la fois
du cinéma mais aussi du vaudeville du
burlesque dans certains corps biolay
s'est dit qu'on avait vu strip tease
d'un travail de l'umoa puis détour de
deux numéros de variétés et à sortir des
milliers de personnes et l'on décide de
construire des grandes centrales de 1000
place de la compétition il ya deux
grandes familles de compétition la
famille la one qui est d'origine
syrienne libanaise et un immigrant grec
monsieur gannett acoss qui a deux
compagnies rivales alors ça stimule la
construction une surenchère une
émulation on veut avoir la plus belle
salle exactement il en reste combien
parce que on connaît le bon société
l'ancien cinéma 5 sur sherbrooke on
verra ça marche il ya le cinéma
autrement il ya plus de films et ça a
été rouvert pour des spectacles rialto
corona le château et métaux scop qu'elle
convient mais il reste peut-être une
dizaine sociaux qui en a certains qu'on
ne remarque pas parce que c'est devenu
si je prends par exemple sur ses propos
sur saint denis nass et cinéma qui est
devenu jean coutu il ya des cinémas qui
sont devenus des lieux talent ils ont
ils sont encore debout c'est déjà ça
mais ils ont d'autres vocations mais et
vous vous aimez l'histoire est ce qu'il
ya un avenir assez salée ce que mal un
métier qu'on voit dans le reportage sa
chambre pour une bonne cause c'est ce
qu'on peut trouver une autre vocation
mais je pense le défi des deux cinémas
c'est un peu comme des défis des églises
en cinéma c'est un peu les temples la
culture populaire de l'époque que les
grands magasins les banques c'est le
même décor alors je pense que au fond
d'avoir réussi pendant des années de
trouver d'autres vocations et ça c'est
l'histoire de tous les cinémas sur
sainte-catherine y avait une dizaine de
cinémas du début du siècle la plupart
sont fermées aujourd'hui il y en a
certains qui ont survécu pendant
quelques années entre autres passé
devenus des cinémas de sexe alors c'est
ça l'amour c'est ça alors si le premier
à montréal cinéma l'amour qui fonctionne
fort nous dit-on mais cinéma qu'on voit
là les grands d'exceptionnel
c'est la première salle oui c'est je
pense ce soit au fond des bâtiments
comme ça le pire scénario c'est
l'abandon
alors si c'est si cinéma devient autre
chose alors peut-être qu'un jour à une
certaine époque on disait c'est
important de rénover comme ça se passe
pour l'un plus et c'est un peu ça au
fond l'important c'est de faut que les
gens les aiment demanda les élus au fond
de faire quelque chose
est-ce que ça doit devenir un cinéma ou
autre chose ça c'est bon
c'est la question mais il en reste peu
je pense qu'il faut les protéger on voit
le théâtre corona l'écran ça c'est un
bel exemple l'instauration parce qu'ils
ont regardé la patine du temps à
l'horizon pas restauré à l'identique de
ce qui était au début du siècle mais ils
ont gardé les traces du passage du temps
et les synthés fait de façon très
artistique vraiment très bien donc je
pense que c'est cinéma est ce que c'est
la reconstitution totale peut-être pas
mais ça fait des lieux magiques
je pense que c'est sûr qu'on cherche ou
font aujourd'hui encore les jeunes
cherchent l'expérience ont conçu des
décors artificiels ont sans volant
virtuel cellule a naturellement il crée
une expérience et il suffit d'entrer
dans cl d'eau pour sentir la magie
évidemment on est au centre-ville les
modes ont changé des multiplexes en
banlieue bon il faut trouver des
stratégies pour ramener les gens dans
ces lieux
c'est à ce succès tout un défi comme ça
l'était à l'époque mais ça fait partie
en conclusion monsieur leclerc de l'âme
de montréal il ya quelque chose de
traitement réel ceylan de montréal comme
nous à l'exposition au scandale au
centre d'histoire on présente ce mois
des années 40-50 montréal ville de
plaisir
montreal ville d'innovation les gens
étaient curieux l'armorial depuis le
début du siècle sont l'oublient souvent
ce n'est pas l'épreuve seulement de
séraphine est alors moi je pense c'est
ça l'esprit de montréal et les dents
cellule ça a été mon ancêtre de la ville
métropole culturelle à la faute est
respecté ce qui nous ont légué ses
ancêtres de notre métropole culturelle
on souhaite que la presse fonctionne et
qui a d'autres projets sur le clair
merci de me voir le plus à la prochaine
le projet nommé messieurs commentaires
suggestions là dessus et sur d'autres
sujets on vous lit avec beaucoup
d'attention